Claude dropped Fable 5 and Claude Mythos
5. So, Fable 5 will be available to the
public. Essentially, it is Mythos 5 with
some guardrails in place so that people
can use it safely. And Claude Mythos 5
is going to be open for some bigger
players in the market that get unlimited
access to it. So, in today's video, I
wanted to see if Claude Fable 5 can
actually write better SEO content, do
better SEO audits, and give us better
results than the previous Claude models.
So, we've actually added in Fable 5 on
Word Rocket. So, it's under testing. If
you scroll all the way down, I will
launch this later today where you can
actually test and use Fable 5 for
yourself. It is very expensive, so I
probably wouldn't use it to write
content on a day-to-day basis, but it is
good to test it out to see the
benchmarks of how it performs. So, the
first article that we wrote was the best
AI marketing tools of 2026. I wanted to
do this to see if it could actually find
more up-to-date tools rather than the
generic tools that they usually give
you. So, if we scroll down here, we can
see that it did use the references
like it usually does. The article looks
pretty decent.
The cover image looks decent. The best
AI marketing tools of 2026 falls into
five categories. It just gives you the
categories, key takeaways, and then we
get the fan out questions because this
is GEO optimized.
Overall, I would say that this is a
decent article.
I like that it kind of has a mixture of
tables, of pull quotes, of actual
bullet points as well. But, was it worth
using Fable 5? So, if I go over to
Fable, we can see here Fable 5 is 0.67
cent per article. So, that is pretty
high, 67 cents, which is if you compare
that to Sonnet, Sonnet is like 13 cent.
So, you know, five times higher the
cost, I don't think it's worth it for
the quality of the output that we get
back. Now, I actually went ahead and did
something else, which I think would be
much more useful. I used Fable 5 in on
Claude
desktop app. And then I use my SERP to
publish SEO. So essentially, this is
going to go out. You give it one
keyword. It's going to search the SERP,
do competitive research based upon what
the top-ranked articles are doing, and
then it's going to take that information
and write our own unique article. So we
see here, it found the title, Niagara to
Toronto tours, and then it actually went
ahead and posted the article cuz it
wrote the article using the WordRocket
MCP.
It created two images.
And it had a strategy a strategy note.
So the SERP is almost entirely
uh Toronto to Niagara. So the article
was angled to own the reverse direction.
So Niagara base uh travelers heading
from into Toronto. Right? So if it's
telling me the strategy that it used
here.
And we can see if I go through the
actual steps, it went ahead and searched
up all of these specific websites, and
it found the information. So I found
that um Fable actually was more um
concise in doing its research and
getting me the output much quicker. If
you go ahead and take a look at the
article, I'm going to go ahead and open
up this article here. We can see that it
posted the article with no problems
directly over to the site. And that is
what Fable is good for. It's good at
doing tasks, not at just writing
content. So I'd recommend using any of
our SOPs. We have about 11 SOPs um on
our website. If you want to get access
to it, just comment SOP below and I'll
send you over all of our SEO SOP. But it
did a pretty good job
with researching and writing and then
posting the article directly over to our
website here.
So again, if I go back over to articles,
um we can see here that it did use our
WordRocket integration here, but because
it
And it did use our WordRocket
integration here to write the article
and post it over to our website. Lastly,
I went ahead and asked uh Fable 5 to
write an article on how to grow a
LinkedIn page in 2026 from a
first-person perspective. To grow a
LinkedIn page, da da da, post three to
three to five times. Growth in 2026
rewards consistency and genuine
conversation. Key takeaways,
I will get the fan out questions. It
looks like everything is very very um
very kind of uniform in terms of the
output. So, we get the opening
paragraph, then we get our bullet
points, common mistake, edge case, and
we kind of get that same thing as well
for both of the paragraphs because
again, this is a very powerful model.
So, it's going to do things very very um
sort of linear. But, if you take a look
at the references, those are all
included. For our GEO insights, we got
80 out of 100 and they used 12 out of
the 13 fan out questions, which is
pretty good. In terms of readability, we
got a readability of grade 10, but I
could definitely go ahead and uh reduce
that if I change the setting on Word
Rocket. So, overall, I would say that
you have to give it more complex tasks
if you wanted to do full workflows of
doing competitive advantage on your
competitors and then writing an article
based upon that. I think it did really
really well um I gathering that
information.
And for a period of time, you can use it
in your Claude uh desktop
for completely free. If you guys want to
get my SOPs, again, just comment SOP
below and I'll send you over our 20 plus
SOPs that you can choose from and use it
in Claude Fable and get some good
results. Hope that you guys enjoyed
today's video. I'll see you in the next
one. Take care.